مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوينها
برعايه عمانيه اتفاق وشيك بين واشنط
وطهران على اطلاق رهائن امريكيين واجواء
ايجابيه حول النووي
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه تكشف عن نسب التضخم
في مايو وايجارات المساكن المؤثر الاكبر
مع ارتفاع بلغ 10%
وزير الاعلام اليمني يعلن تدشين اولى
رحلات نقل الحجاج من مطار صنعاء الى جده
والمدينه
رابع ايضا
نمو شركات الدفع الاجل في السعوديه يثير
التساؤلات استهلاك اعلى لسلع ليس الضروريه
والمكسيك تعيش ليله فنيه سعوديه المحطه
الثانيه لروائع الموسيقى السعودي
فصل جديد من فصول العلاقات الامريكيه
الايرانيه هذه المرات تتجه نحو التفاهم
ربما بعيدا عن لغه التهديد محادثات غير
مباشره يجيها الطرفان في سلطنه عمان تبادل
من خلالها رسائل عبر مسؤولين عمانيين ولم
يلتقي الجانبان وجها لوجه وزير الخارجيه
العماني بدر البوسعيدي قال ان ايران
والولايات المتحده تقتربان من وضع اللمسات
النهائيه على اتفاق بشان اطلاق سراح
امريكيين في الظلام مشيرا الى ان المساله
تنحصر في امور فنيه فقط واوضح الوزير
النيران كان لديها شروط اولها الافراج عن
اصول ايرانيه بمليارات الدولارات مجمده في
بنوك كوريا الجنوبيه بسبب عقوبات امريكيه
البوسعيد عبر ايضا عن تفائله حول الاتفاق
النووي الايراني الذي ابرم عام 2015 قائلا
ان هناك اجواء ايجابيه فيما يخص الملف
النووي وان بلاده تعتقد ان القياده
الايرانيه جاده
بشان التوسل الاتفاق
تنضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي حسن فحص سيد حسن
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
ما يتم تداوله الان في اكثر من وسيله
وكاله
هناك مفاوضات تجري بهدوء خلف الكواليس بين
اداره الرئيس الامريكي مع ايران للحد من
البرنامج النووي وربما بدات بعض المؤشرات
الايجابيه بالاتفاق على اطلاق سراح
الامريكيين المسجونيين لكن هل بات اولا
هذا الاتفاق هو شيكا تم او يتم وضع
اللمسات النهائيه وهل تلتقي الاهداف
النهائيه للطرفين امريكا وايران ضمن هذا
الاتفاق
تحياتي استاذ خالد
العاملين والمشاهدين
يعني يبدو ان المواقف المتسارعه والتحركات
التي تشهدها كل من ابو ظبي وعمان
او سلطنه عمان العاصمه مسقط من حراك
ايراني باتجاه الاداره الامريكيه اولا
الاوروبيه يوحي بان
الامور وصلت الى
المراحل المتقدمه جدا
وقد تكون في
اشواطها الاخيره يعني
للتواصل الى صيغه
متفاهم عليها بين هذه الاطراف او يعني
واشنطن مع طهران لاعاده انتاج اتفاق
يسمح بالعوده الى اتفاق 2015
مع بعض التعديلات التي تطالب بها طهران
ايضا
وتتمسك بها الولايات المتحده وخاصه ما
يتعلق بموضوع التخصيب باليوراني ومستوى
هذا التخصيب وحجم الاجهزه التي
ركبتها طهران في منشاتها وفي مساعيها
للحفاظ على هذه المنشات من دون تخريب كما
حصل في عام 2015 بالاتفاق السابق لذلك
يبدو ان الامور وصلت الى مراحل متقدمه
قد تكون الخطوه الاولى هي
في الاتفاق على اطلاق
الاسرى او المعتقلين الامريكيين في السجون
الامر الايرانيه وايضا بعض المعتقلين
الايرانيين في السجون الامريكيه
بالاضافه الى اطلاق
يعني جزء من الاموال المجمده هناك اختلاف
حول حجمها بين 17 مليار الى 24 مليار
دولار
ولكن هذه الاطلاق الاموال لن يكون مباشره
لصالح البنك المركزي الايراني وانما
سيستخدم عبر البنك المركزي العماني لتلبيه
الحاجات الاقتصاديه الضروريه للمجتمع
الايراني والدوله الايرانيه يعني كما حصلت
مع في اطلاق حوالي 2.7 مليار دولار من
الاموال الايرانيه في العراق في الايام
الاخيره
وهذه الاموال نقلت الى البحث المركزي
العماني
وسيط لتلبيه الحاجات والمشتريات الايرانيه
لذلك يعني
الايراني يسعى الى ان تكون هذه الاطلاقات
للاموال المجمده لصالح البنك المركزي
الايراني ولا تحصر بما يشبه قانون
النفط مقابل الغذاء وبالتالي تسعى ايضا
الى
العوده الى سوق الاسواق الدوليه للطاقه من
البيع المباشر
والحصول على عائدات كل كل هذه الشروط ربما
او المطالبات والمسار الذي تسلكه هذه
المفاوضات هل ستؤدي الى الى اتفاق رسمي او
غير رسمي وغير مكتوب كما جاء في صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كهدف امريكي
او اتفاق مؤقت ام اتفاق يعني ربما كامل
كما يريده الايرانيون حتى يتجنبوا الحرج
الداخلي ربما الذي يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
دعنا نتفق اولا ان النظام الايراني لا
يريد اي اتفاق مؤقت لان الوصول الى اتفاق
مؤقت
قد يعني يعتبر هزيمه له خاصه وانه رفع
شعار
تعديل
وتحسين الاتفاق السابق لذلك الاتفاق
المؤقت هو اقل كثيرا من الاتفاق 2015 لذلك
هو يسعى لان يذهب الى خطوه
تمهد للاتفاق الاكبر
من دون ان يكون محرجا في الداخل
ويحقق
يعني تطورا في الشروط التي جاءت في
الاتفاق السابق او خاصه ما يتعلق والكلام
المرشد الايراني كان واضحا جدا عندما اعطى
الضوء الاخضر للسيب المفاوضات واعتبر ان
ان ما يجري هو جيد من غير مباشره ولكن يجب
ان يتنبه الجميع من الفريق الايراني
المفاوض ان لا يقعوا في فخ ما حدث في
السابق عندما اجبرت ايران على تخفيض اجهزه
طب المركزي والاكتفاء بعدد قليل منها يسمح
لها بانتاج كميات محدوده من اليوراني
وخاصه سواء بمستوى ثلاثه فاصل خمسه او
المستوى 20% من من التخصيب لذلك الان
التفاوض يدور حول
الاستمرار في هذه الاجهزه البقاء هذه
الاجهزه المنصوبه وفعاله ونشطه وايضا رفع
مستوى
امكانيه العمل على
الحصول على مستوى 60
ربما العلميه عندما تحدث عن اتفاق
يعني يقدنا صفه كما يذهب البعض الى اتفاق
متواضع هل سيجنب تماما من حدود او من حدوث
الازمات ربما الحروب في هذه المنطقه هل
يفي بغرض متابعه الانشطه النوويه التي
تجري تحت الارض ما اشعر مؤخرا يعني ضمن
مشات جديده بنيت تحت الارض في نفس هل
امريكا معنيه ايضا بوضع شروط متعلقه بمثلا
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتداعياتها
ومنع ايران او ايقاف ايران عن امداد الروس
بالمسيرات بالصواريخ البلاستيكيه
استاذ خالد يعني اللقاء الذي حصل في
العاصمه الاماراتيه ابوظبي بين باقي مع
نظرائه من التويكل الاوروبيه
يعني يشير الى ان الجانب الاوروبي
الالماني الاكثر في الحرب الاوكرانيه
قد لا يقل عن الاداره الامريكيه
في
باهميه الحرب الاوكرانيه بالنسبه له وهو
الذي رفع مستوى التحديات مع ايران وفرض
جمله من العقوبات لم تكن في السابق او لم
يلجا اليها في السابق نتيجه الدوري
الايراني في الحرب الاوكرانيه الى جانب
روسيا ولكن هذا اللقاء يؤشر الى ان
الجماعه او هذه الاطراف تريد ان تصل الى
اتفاق يسمح لها بتعزيز دور الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في مراقبه البرنامج
النووي الايراني والح من تطويره والوصول
به الى مستويات متقدمه الهم الاساسي الذي
تعمل عليه الاداره الامريكيه وكما واضح
وكما هو واضح من جميع المواقف التي تصدر
عن هذه الاداره ومعها الاوروبيين عدم
السماح لطهران
بتصنيع العسكري او الانتقال الى المستوى
العسكري في البرنامج النووي الايراني حتى
من دون تصنيع ولكن هذا امتلاك هذه
التقنيات يشكل تهديدا
اتفاق اسرائيل
نعم اسرائيل هل ستقبل بهكذا اتفاق ضمن هذه
الشروط والاهداف
لا اعتقد ان الاداره التل ابيب ستقبل باي
اتفاق يكرس ايران لاعبا اقليميا سواء على
المستوى النووي او على مستوى النفود
السياسي وحتى على مستوى الانفتاح الذي
بداته
باتجاه الدول العربيه والذي شكل صدمه
عندما عند الاعلان عن الاتفاق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لك حسن فحص
الكاتب الصحفي ضيفي من بيروت
باريس المكلف بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في
الخارجيه الفرنسيه باتريس اهلا وسهلا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه كيف يمكن النظر الان
الى الواقع العلاقات السعوديه الفرنسيه في
ضوء هذه الزياره وفي ضوء ايضا الملفات
التي يتفق عليها عليها البلد
شكرا لهذا السؤال
اذا سابدا
بالشراكه ثابته بين فرنسا والسعوديه
وزاره الخارجيه
مؤخرا للمشاركه في
مؤتمر اجتماع وزاري التحالف ضد تنظيم داعش
كان هذا ملف مهم جدا يعني
مصالح مشتركه هدف مشترك بين السعوديه
وفرنسا الكفاح ضد الارهاب
في هذه المناسبه التقت
بناديرها السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
وتطرقوا الى بعض الملفات من هذه الملفات
الملف اللبناني العلاقه الثنائيه
وبيننا كما سابقا
شراكه ثابته تشمل كل الابعاد ونحن نود
تعميق هذه العلاقات السعيده الثقافي مثلا
مشاريع رمزيه مثل الاولى على الصعيد
الاقتصادي وطبعا كما تفضلت سيشارك
الاسبوع الجاي ولي العهد السعودي في قمه
حول الميثاق المالي الجديد وهذا يعني يعني
ان بين فرنسا وسعوديه
ملفات مشاركه على لكن ايضا اهتمام على
الصعيد العالمي فيما يتقدم التحديات
العالميه في الملف اللبناني الى اي مدى
هناك تفاهمات او الالتقاء في المواقف بين
الرياض وباريس سيد باتريس
اولا
سيتطرق الرئيس
قريبا هذا الملف ايضا
نحن على اتصال مستمر مع كل الاطراف التي
قد تساعد في
الخروج من المازق الحالي في لبنان لن
نتشاورت مع السعوديه بالذات
وعلى هامش
مؤتمر الوزاري حول كفاح الكفاح ضد داعش
انتقت ايضا
بزميل زميله اللبناني
بو حبيب فنحن مع حل لبناني على لبنانيين
ان ينتخبوا رئيسا رئيسا يا جماعه رئيسا
يعين رئيس وزراء ورئيس حكومه لبناني قادر
على اخذ
قرارات اللازمه لمعالجه الازمه الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه في في لبنان هذا ما
نشارك يعني
السودان اليوم يعيش منعطف ربما قد يتجه
فيه الصراع الى منحنى خطر جدا وهذا ما
حضرت منه الكثير من المنظمات
الدوليه مؤخرا كيف يتم التفاهم ايضا
والتنسيق في المواقف بين رياض وباريس حول
هذه الازمه
يعني
لنتجنب اي ملف
وما ذكرنا لكن الميلاد الاوكراني
ايضا سيكون على المائده بين سعودي وفرنسا
في زياره ولي العهد فيما ترى بالسودان نحن
عبرنا عن دعمنا لكل الجهود المبذوله من
السعوديه من الولايات المتحده
لوقت اطلاق النار لهدنه
المستدام
لسببين اولا لاسباب انسانيه لمعالجه
الازمه القاسيه التي يعاني عنها
السودانيون حاليا في في البلد وهذا يعني
ازمه
عبرنا عن دعمنا للجهود المبذوله السعوديه
من هذا الحرب استنزاف
لايجاده الطريق لحل سياسي يشمل كل الاطراف
لكن ايضا المجتمع المدني او الفعاليات
المجتمع المدنيه السوداني هذا ما يجمعنا
بين السعوديه وفرنسا وقد اذكر ايضا اننا
شاركنا في مجلس الجوي الى جيوتي لكن ايضا
عمليه اشلاء
الاجانب من من السودان عبر السعوديه في
تعاون وثيق جدا بين السعوديه وفرنسا شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد باتريس
المكلف بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في
الخارجيه الفرنسيه من باريس
في الرابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بشكل شهري تجري او تجري
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه تقييما لمؤشر
التضخم الزميله شهد المتروك تعرفنا على
ابرز ارقام التضخم هذا خلال هذا الشهر شهر
او شهر ماي الماضي عفوا
اذا
كتعوديه عن ارتفاع مؤشر الرقم القياسي لا
سعار او ما يعرف بالتضخم الى اثنين فاصل
ثمانيه اعشار في المئه خلال شهر مايو
مقارنه بنفس الفتره من العام الماضي عشرين
اثنين وعشرين اسعار الايجارات الفعليه
للمساكن المؤثر الاكبر على ارتفاع التضخم
في السعوديه على اساس سنوي حيث وصلت نسبه
الارتفاع الى نحو عشره في المئه خلال مايو
الماضي سجلت هذه الارقام نتيجه ارتفاع
اسعار ايجارات الشقق باكثر من ثلاثه
وعشرين في المئه خلال ذات الفتره مقارنه
بالعام الماضي 20 22 دعونا نلقي نظره على
ارتفاع اسعار الخدمات الاخرى السكن
والمياه والكهرباء ارتفعت باكثر من 8% في
محله المطاعم والفنادق في المرتبه الثانيه
بخمسه في المئه ثم انشطه الثقافه والترفيه
بنحو اربعه في المئه اسعار التعليم ارتفع
الاخرى بثلاثه في المئه خلال مايو الماضي
كيف يتم قياس التضخم سؤال يتكرر بين فتره
واخرى هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه اوضحت ان
المؤشره يقيس اسعار 490 سلعه وخدمه عبر
جولات ميدانيه لنقاط البيع بشكل شهري
للرياض ينضمرين الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
السيد عبد الله حياك الله معي يعني من
خلال ما نتابع كل شيء مرتفع في المملكه
بسبب التضخم هل الامر طبيعي اول
طبعا يعني اليوم البيئه التضخميه موجوده
لكن الكلام دائما هو كم مستوى التضخم الذي
يتم القبول فيه
المستويات المتعارف عليها تاريخيا كانت
بحدود الاثنين في المئه على اساس سنوي انه
يكون في ارتفاع في اثنين في المئه
الارتفاع المقبول واللي يعتبر تحت السيطره
هو 2% بالنسبه لارتفاع اسعار القدمات
اللي يستهلكها المواطن
فلما يكون عندنا ارتفاعات اكثر من اثنين
في المئه يبدا هناك زي ما هو عندنا
هو يعتبر مرتفع لكنه ليس مرتفع بالشكل
المقلق وليس مرتفع كذلك خالد بالمقارنه
مع رنج شهري يناير الماضي الماضي كان
ارتفاع يناير 23 عمي يناير 22 ثلاثه وشوي
في المئه فاليوم احنا نتكلم على مستوى اقل
لكن ما زال شوي مرتفع ولو رجعنا زي ما ذكر
في التقرير يعني كان واحد من اهم المحركات
او الاسباب ارتفاع التضخم وطبعا اسعار
الايجارات ولو رجعنا الاسعار الايجارات
حنلقاه انه كان مصدرها الرئيسي كان في
مدينه الرياض وهذا شيء منطقي حسب مجريات
والاحداث التي تحصل الان في الرياض من
استقطاب للشركات العالميه وهجره كثير من
الباحثين عن العمل للرياض ادى الى طلب
كبير على المنازل والمساكن والاجارات
فانا ارى منطقيا ولا كذلك نفس الوقت يعني
مقلق لانه احنا نزلنا اقل بكثير من
المستويات اللي حول العالم امريكا مثلا
على سبيل المثال اعلى من هذه الارقام
بكثير واعلى من هذه المعدلات
المعدلات عندنا اقل حتى من بدايه السنه
المتوقع وحتى في تقرير الاستقرار المالي
ارتفع الاسعار الفائده مثلا صحيح انه هي
مسيره من لمواجهه التضخم لكن تنزل الاسعار
العقار بشكل عام الايجارات وغيرها هذا
صحيح ولا لا يعني في امريكا على سبيل
المثال
كل تاكيد هذا هو الهدف من اللي عندنا
استخدام اداه رفع اسعار الفائده نعم اليوم
اسعار الفائده من متى بدات ترتفع في السنه
الماضيه بدات ترتفع من منتصف الثاني من
سنه 22 فلذلك احنا نقيس اسعار الفائده
الان مع اسعار الفائده كانت مختلفه عن
الماضي التاثيرات الحقيقيه تبدا معانا مع
النصف الثاني النصف الثاني متوقع وحسب حتى
كذلك تقرير البنك المركزي انه نشوف
الفائده اسف التضخم في مستويات اقل خلال
السته شهور القادمه باذن الله
يظل دائما هناك اشياء
هو المشكله ربما الان الارتفاع بشكل مضطرد
بشكل كبير يعني اتكلم عن 10% تقريبا عن
الشهر الماضي
الارتفاع
لابد ان ناخذ الامور من زواياها جميعا
يعني اسعار الفائده مؤثر لكن لا تنسى انه
اليوم في ضغط على مدينه الرياض في المساكن
فالضغط هذا لا يقابله ما زال
العرض ما زال يعني محدود نوعا ما في عرضه
موجود لكن الطلب اصبح كبير وسريع
اليوم هذا اوجد شوي ارتفاع في الايجارات
لكن ليس في الاسعار العقارات نفسها لكن في
الايجارات جيد شكرا لك عبد الله الربدي
رئيس التنفيذي لشركه راسان الماليه
كشف وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر العرياني ان
الخطوط الجويه سوف تدشن يوم السبت اولى
رحلات نقل الحجاج من صنعاء لجده والمدينه
مؤكد اننا نقل الحجاج اليمنيين من صنعاء
جاء بالتوجيهات من الرئيس اليمني والتعاون
السعودي نجربها اعلنت وزاره الحج والعمر
السعودي عن تيسير رحلات الحجاج اليمنيين
القادمين لاداء فريضه الحج لهذا العام
واداء العمره من مطار صنعاء الى مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
[موسيقى]
ايضا في اخبار الحج حيث يتوجه ثلاثه الاف
وستمائه شخص من بريطانيا الى السعوديه
لاداء شعائر الحج هذا العام زميل مصطفى
زارو التقى ثلاثه من حجاج بريطانيا
محمد هلال ومحمد الشذري ومحمد امين ثلاثه
اصدقاء من اصل بنغالي ذاهبون رفقه ازواجهم
لاداء فريضه الحج
قلق رفقهم خلال عمليه التسجيل حتى تاكيد
حجزهم لخوض هذه الرحله الايمانيه
لن نتصور كم كنت سعيدا عندما تاكد ذهاب
لاعداء مناسك الحج لاول مره مع زوجتي وهذا
من فضل الله تعالى
بوابه الكترونيه اعتمدتها وزاره الحج
والعمره لتطوير التجربه الرقميه لضيوف
الرحمن من اوروبا وامريكا واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا بدءا من تسجيل عمليه الترشح
والقبول الى اختيار باقه الحج من الشركات
النظاميه ضمن الجهود المبذوله لتسهيل
الاجراءات
محظوظ من يستطيع حج بيت الحرم وسط ازمه
غلاء المعيشه ومحظوظ اكثر على من يحصل على
احد الاماكن المحدوده المخصصه للراغبين في
الحج من بريطانيا هذا العام الحمد لله
انا جدا محظوظ كما تعرف اكثر من 20 الف
شخص يذهبون الى الحج من بريطانيا والعدد
الان تم تقليصه الى قرابه 4000 شخص انا
جدا متحمس ومحظوظ لخوض هذه الرحله
الروحانيه
الكثير تغير وانا متحمس لتجربه هذا النظام
الجديد للحج وانوي اداء مناسك الحج بقدر
المستطاع على افضل وجه
هؤلاء الاصدقاء الثلاثه استكملوا جميع
متطلبات السفر الى مكه والمدينه تلقوا
الارشادات الوقائيه والنصائح اللازمه
اثناء اداء شعائر ومناسك الحج وحزموا
حقائبهم للانضمام الى الحجاج من كافه
انحاء العالم مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
بقرار مجلس الوزراء السعودي نظام
المعاملات المدنيه بعد استكمال الاجراءات
النظاميه لدراسه في مجلس الشورى ويعد نظام
المعاملات المدنيه ثالث المشروعات منظومه
التشريعات المتخصصه ويشتمل على احكام تحدد
جميع ما يتعلق بالعقودات النظام باداف رفع
كفاءه الانظمه وحمايه الحقوق وتعزيز
الشفافيه كما سيكون ايضا مرجعا لتنظيم
العلاقه بين الافراد في تعاملهم او
تعاملاتهم وسيحد من حالات المنازعات بين
الافراد فضلا عن تقليل امد الفصل في
الخصومات
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا عضو مجلس الشورى
الدكتور فيصل الفاضل حياك الله دكتور
انا ودي اول شيء لو نبسط هذا النظام
الجديد للناس
باللغه
بسيطه جدا ماذا يعني النظام ما هي اهم
فوائد
طبعا زي ما تفضلتم في التقديم يعني يعتبر
هذا النظام احد اهم الانظمه
التشريعيه القضائيه لا يمكن زي ما تفضلت
عشان نبسط الامر النظام هذا هو عباره عن
مجموعه من الاحكام والقواعد اللي تنظم
الاحكام المتعلقه
بتعاملات الافراد العقود المعاملات
الماليه بينهم يعني على سبيل المثال خلينا
نقول
عقد من العقود بين طرفيها خلينا نقول عقد
بيع او عقد ايجار
هذا النظام يحتوي على احكام شامله
ومتكامله تتعامل مع هذه العقود مع هذه
المعاملات بحيث انه الاطراف يعرفون مالهم
من حقوق وما عليهم من واجبات ويستطيعون
حتى عندهم قدره على التنبه في حال لو صار
نزاع لا سمح الله وراحوا للقضاء يعرفون
ما هو الحكم الذي سيصدر يعني سيصبح فيه
وضوح يعني هذه ممكن اهم المزايا النظام في
شفافيه في وضوح ايضا في حوكمه يعني وهذا
جدا مهمه انه ايضا القاضي بدل ما يكون لا
حريه واسعه يستر الحكم الذي يراه اصبح
مقيد بهذا التقنيه الامامنا اللي هو نظام
المعاملات المدنيه يعني ما في تباين في
هذا احد احد اهم مزايا هذا النظام انه يحد
من التباين في الاحكام القضائيه يعني نقدر
نقول انه هنا امام حاله تاريخيه ما قبل
نظام المعاملات الالكترونيه وما سيكون بعد
نظام المعاملات الكترونيه تقصد
او النظام المعاملات المدنيه نعم يعني
وطبعا هو في الدول الاخرى يعني
يسمونها القوم المدني
وطبعا هو مطبق يعني نحن ما جبنا شيء جديد
يعني القول هذا المدني طبعا العالم كله
ينقسم في دول النظاميه يسمونها الاندوسك
سوني اللي هي بريطانيا
وفي دول وهي تقريبا 150 دولار اللي تتبع
النظام اللي هو النظام
المدني وهذا الان يعني وهذا كل الدول
العربيه الدول
نفسها انظمه نفس الدول الخليج عندهم قانون
مدني اللي حنا نسميه نظام المعاملات
المدنيه وطبعا هو يعتبر قبل ابو القوانين
الخاصه يسمونه ابو القوانين ليش لانه
يعتبر المرجعيه الاساسيه طبعا يكون في
تفريعات زي قانون تجاري قانون عمل قانون
السياحي او قانون وهكذا لكن في النهايه
اذا ما في نصوص تنظم تلك المعاملات الخاصه
شيخنا نقول معاناه التجاريه بتكون
بالاجتهاد يرجع للنظام المعاملات المدنيه
فيعتبر المرجعيه النهائيه المهم في
الموضوع من الميزه من هذا التقليل ان في
وضوح ما عاد في غياب وفي فراغ تشريعي
اصبحت عندنا منظومه تشريعيه معاصره وتواكب
المستجدات طبعا ايضا من مزايا النظ انه
ينسجم مع الاتفاقيه الدوليه اللي انضمت
لها المملكه منسجم معها تماما ايضا ما
يتعارض مع احكام الشريعه الاسلاميه اللي
هي يعني الاساس في هالبلد يعني شخص في
امريكا عنده هذا النظام نظام القانون
المدني لما يجي هنا مثلا بيستثمر بيجد نفس
هذا النظام الموجود في بلاده وموجود هنا
ومطبق صح ولا لا ما يختلف باي شكل من
الاشكال طبعا الاحكام تختلف لكن القانون
مثلا على سبيل المثال المستثمر ايش اللي
يهمه اللي على اساس انه يبدا في مشروع
معين يحرف يبي يعرف الكوست يحسب التكاليف
من ضمنها التكاليف القضائيه يعني لو صار
نزاع هل سيضمن انه يحصل على حقوقه لو لو
الطرف الاخر
تاخر او او قصر في تنفيذ التزامه هذا
النظام بوضوحه وبشفافيته وبمعرفته
المستثمر يشجع صلاح يوفر به استثماريه
جاذبه
يكون القاضي الان هو يطبق القاضي
لا ينقضي عنده قانون عنده نظام معدنه
للقانون
يكيف الحاله يرجع للمواد النظاميه يعني
خلينا نقول خلنا نقول عقد يرجع للاحكام
الخاصه بالبيع خلينا نقول تعويض في احد
جاي ما في راح يكون في تباين
الاهداف يعني انه يحد من التبعين ايضا
يعني هذه ميزه من مزايا للقضاء انه في
درجه اولى بعد الدرجه الاولى وهذه مجال
يعني لو كان احد الاطراف يرى ان القاضي لم
يطبق اهل النصوص يستطيع انه يستانف وتاتي
جهه قضائيه او مجموعه قضائيه محكمه جديده
من غير القضات السابقين
ويتاكدون ويراجعون ويعيدون اذا كان في
انحراف يعيدنا الى الوضع فبالتالي بنخرج
بجوده قضائيه واضحه شكرا جزيلا على هذه
الافاده دكتور فيصل الفاضل عضو مجلس
الشورى شكرا حياكم الله يا اهلا وسهلا
نمور كبير تشهد السعوديه لشركات الدفع
الاجله وما تعرف باشتري الان وادفع لاحقا
هذا النمو خلق حاله من الاستهلاك غير
المنضبط كما يرى البعض بين فئات عمريه
مختلفه وترى ايضا تساؤلات حول بعض
السلبيات لهذه الشركات والايجابيات ايضا
الزميل عبد المحسن الحربي والثقل انها
اراء بعض المستفيدين من هذه الخدمات نتابع
يستعرض زيد مع اصدقائه قائمه مشترياته عبر
شركات الدفع الاجل خلال الاشهر الماضيه
شركات عززت من استهلاكه رغم عدم امتلاكه
للسيوله اللازمه تقريبا النينجا راتب فانا
ممكن ما اقدر ادفع 400 ولا 500 مثلا ادفع
مبلغ بسيط اقسم على فتره اشهر اربع شهور
ان على الاقل اوفر شوي ما اتفهم مره وحده
واخر الشهر اجي يكون يعني ما عندي فلوس
ومضايق يعني اسماء وشركات الدفع الاجل
اصبحت على السنتي شباب وشابات من مختلف
الاعمار حل لتلبيه احتياجات وغالبا
كماليات
ها هي مره مساعده مثلا
ما عندي
الحين تاجها مره ابيها للشنطه ولا ابغى
اللبس مره مساعده التطبيقات دي واشكر اللي
سواها صدق سنوات قليله منذ ان دخلت شركات
الدفع الاجل الى السوق حتى اصبحت مقصدا
رئيسيا لفئه عمريه محدده تحديدا وتحدث عن
طلاب الجامعات وكذلك من بداوا حياتهم
المهنيه ما دفع كثير من المحال التجاريه
الى توفير هذه الخدمه طلبا لارادات اكثر
ما تريد وادفعه لاحقا اليه مغريه للمستهلك
ومربحه لقطاعات عده الا انها عكست اضرارا
سلبيه وتستخدم بشكل خاطئ بحسب مستهلكين
انا صراحه حطتنا حلو يعني مستوى نحط لها
مبلغ وقدره على التسديد صله مبلغ خاص اي
مبلغ خاص كل شهر يعني متى ما اسحبه منها
وحلو مره انا عاجبني يعني انا اشوفها من
منظور ثاني انه ممكن سهله لبعض الناس وبعض
الناس استخدمت استخدام خاطئ فقط لا غير
يعني
كل انسان
التكاليف واحتياجاتها ويدفع على قدها يعني
علشان ما يصير مديون يعني كل واحد حسب
قدرته يعني ويكيف امور الماديه حسب
امكانياته والكماليات الزايده الاضافيه
بتاخذ ب 60 ريال تقصدها تاخذ 80 ريال
بتقصدها اربعين تطلع اخر الشارع عليك 600
ريال 700 ريال تقعد تقصدها هذه مشكلتها
يعني
نمو كبير لشركات الدفع الاجل في السعوديه
اخر شواهده ترخيص البنك المركزي لشركتين
جديدتين في الجانب الاخر مستهلكون وجدوا
انفسهم عاجزين عن السداد وفي دوامه
التزامات لا تنتهي عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه الرياض
الله يحييك تابعت التقرير عبد المجيد
خليني اسالك انتو اليوم وشو حجم النمو
الحاله اللي تعيش في شركات الدفع الاجل
النمو اللي شفناه كان النمو يعتبر
استثنائي حتى مقارنه باليسار في العالم
كله يعني النموذج هذا النموذج اصبح منتشر
في العالم
من امريكا الى اليابان
لكن في السعوديه وفي المنطقه هنا كان
النمو استثنائي مقارنه باي مكان في العالم
والسبب هو ان العميل السعودي او العميل
المقيم يعتبر
غير مخدوم وخاصه فئات معينه من البنوك
السعوديه
والبنوك
السعوديه والبنوك اللي في المنطقه بنوك
جدا محافظه تاريخ الى اليوم هي جدا محافظه
في موضوع ما يتعلق بتدين العملاء واعطائهم
قروض فكثير من الشركات الخاصه مثلا
موظفينها ما يقدرون يروحون ياخذون قروض من
البنوك طلاب الجامعه
اصحاب الاعمال الحره
هذولي جميعا ما يدخل مرحله انه يكون مقبول
عند البنت عند البنك السعودي الا اذا كان
من شركات مثلا مدرجه او شركه او جهات
حكوميه او شركات شبه حكوميه والان انت زي
ما انت عارف غالب السعوديين وحتى المقيمين
موظفين في القطاع الخاص في توجه كبير قطاع
الخاص وتوجه صغير للشركات الصغيره
المتوسطه هذه الجهات غير مخدومه من قطاع
البنكي بحكم بحكم ان القطاع البنكي طريقته
في التدين او في القروض عطني ضمان قبل ما
افكر كيف اعطيك مبلغ حنا ما تحس انه انتم
كمان خلقتوا مشكله غاب مجيد يعني يمكن انه
السياسات المحافظه للبنوك حده من بعد
الاثار السلبيه للبعض يرى انها وجدت الان
بسبب
ما عاد في سقف انتم من الابره للصاروخ
دخلته حتى في كوب القهوه يا عبد المجيد
ولا لا يمديك واحد مثلا يشتري له كوب قهوه
بعشر ريال تروح السطل هذا صحيح ولا لا اول
شيء لا احنا ما دخلنا في هذه القطاع الى
الان بس اكيد
حتلاقيه بكل شيء شوف احنا دخلنا مبدئين
المبدا الاول ان العميل
صادق وراح يسدد اون تايم مش حرامي
او قادر ان على مسدد لا لا يقدر انه ما
يسدد وبالتالي خاطر سجل الائتماني
وهذا مو طريق البنكيه طريق البنكيه اثبت
لي انك كويس ولا انت سيء
النيه
انا بدور عليك شيء اذا لقيت اذا ما لقيت
شيء سيء امورك طيبه هذا المبدا الاول
المبدا الثاني ان الانسان والمواطن
والمقيم عاقل وليس اهبل يعني قادر على
اتخاذ قرار هل انا اليوم احتاج الشيء هذا
ولا ما احتاج شيء هذا اليوم انا باكل
الاكله هذه ولا مره اكل الاكله هذه لو كنا
بنكون كنظام اقتصادي ندير حياه الانسان
بالتفاصيل هذه انه نقول تعال انت لا تاكل
الا هذه الكميه من الكاليريز انت لا تاكل
لا احنا علينا نوعي كقطاع وبالتالي العميل
هو اللي يتخذ القرار المهم هل
الحل هذا يساعد الناس في شراء ما يحتاجونه
ما في تعارض بين المسائل الانسانيه
الاخلاقيه بتورطوا ناس فيها يعني اكتشفت
مثلا في ناس مراهقين في ناس اطفال يعني
يدخلوا في مشاكل مع اسرهم ربما تورطوا
نفسهم في مبالغ يعني اخر الشهر فبالتالي
يعني ممكن تتعرضوا لهالمشاكل او تعرض
الاسر ايضا انا اقول لك الوجه الاخر من
القطاع المالي
النقطه الاولى احنا ما نعطي مبالغ كبيره
احنا المتوسط اللي يكون على اي عميل
تقريبا 500 ريال
اذا كانت
يعني في المبلغ الكامل واللي يكون عليه
سواء ممكن يكون يسدد 200 في الشهر الى
اخره مقابل البنوك تقريبا تلاقي 50 الف
الى 100 الف
البنوك
تاخذك او ما يعرف
بطريقه كمبياله بحيث انك اذا انت ما سددت
ياخذونك للقضاء ويسجنونك
يوقفون عليك الخدمات
بالمقابل ما عندكم سقف للفئات المستهدفه
للفئات العمريه مثلا لانه قد تتراكم
خلينا نتفق معك انه المشروع رائع مشروع
ذكي جدا اهنيكم عليه يعني بكل الاحوال
ومشروع جيد جدا جدا ذكي قاعد اتكلم عن
المسائل المتعلقه بارهاق بعض الاسر يعني
واحد عنده راتبه 5,000 عنده ثلاث انفار او
اربع انفار ممكن في لحظه من اللحظات يوصل
شيء قصته مكياج على سبيل المثال ب 80 مع
كم غرض ثاني يطلع له 3 هذا نفر واحد صحيح
اثنين ثلاثه ممكن توصل الامر الى 1500 الف
ريال فبالتالي انت بتسبب مشكله كبيره فهل
في قوانين منظمه لفئات عمريه مستهدفه او
غيرها من الامور طبعا احنا ما نخدم اقل من
18 سنه احنا نختم 18 سنه وفوق وحنا نسوي
نعرف عميلك بشكل كامل ونتاكد من سجل لك
الائتماني ونقدمه
ونرفع
بشكل دوري او يومي بالتالي احنا ما نخدم
اي شخص يقدم على تماره لكن النقطه المهمه
خالد هل حنا
في السوق هل الانسان اللي يحتاج 300 ريال
يقدر يلاقيها اليوم
هل في حديثه طيب في 99% من الناس عاقلين
وقادرين انهم يتصرفون بناء على الخيارات
الموجوده في يومهم في واحد بالمئه واقل
يخطئون الاستخدام هل يخطئ
حنا نرفع فقط السمه ما نسوي ولا شيء حنا
لا ناخذك لا نوقف خدماتك
ياثر على سجلك الائتماني بالعكس حنا سجلك
الائتماني اليوم ثقافه ما كانت موجوده في
السابق في السعوديه اليوم بدات تنمو بشكل
كبير الحمد لله بالتالي حنا مبلغ بسيط
بالعكس يساعد العميل على انه من صغره او
غالب عملائنا اول قرض ياخذه معانا ياخذ
مبلغ بسيط يعرف انه ترى في التزام لازم
تسدد وترى المبلغ جدا جدا بسيط يعني
عملائنا تتكلم على 200 ريال في الدفعه
الواحده يعني المبلغ ليس
للبنوك متعوده معوده العملاء عليه انت
فجاه تتعثر عليك 200,000 ولا 50,000 لا
عندنا اذا تعثرت في اسوء الاحوال عليك
5000 ريال على كل حال في جانب الجميع حتى
مهمه ايضا حتى في تثقيف في رفع درجه
الواعيه دور كبير تقومون فيه واشكرك شكر
جزيلا على تواجد حبيبي خالد الله يعافيك
شكرا لشرافتك عبد المجيد الصيخان مؤسس
والرئيس التنفيذي لتمر
حققت الموانئ والسعوديه على تقدم لها في
مؤشر اتصال شبكه الملاحه البحريه ضمن
التقرير الانك لربع الثاني لعام 2023
الصادر من مؤتمر الامم المتحده للتجاره
والتنميه لتحتل المملكه المرتبه السادسه
عشره على مستوى العالم ضمن 187 دوله من
خلال تعدد الخدمات الملاحيه البالغ عددها
سبعا وتسعين خدمه في الموانئ السعوديه
التي تربط المملكه بنحو ثلاثمائه وثمانيه
واربعين بناء عالميا
المكسيك محطه ثانيه لروائع الموسيقى
السعوديه حيث شهدت العاصمه المكسيك ليله
فنيه سعوديه خالده تابعوا بعضا من جمالها
في التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
مبادره ثقافيه تحط رحالها في مكسيكو سيتي
ثاني العواصم الغربيه بعد ليله فارسيه
ناجحه اواخر العام الماضي شهد التالق
الاوركسترا الوطنيه والقرى للسعودي باعمال
من ابرز الاغنيات السعوديه
المبادره السعوديه التي اطلقتها هيئه
الموسيقى لفتت الانظار مجددا هذه المره
بمشاركه اوركسترا كارلوس شافيز المكسيكيه
وعشرات العازفين والفنانين السعوديين
[موسيقى]
لوحه موسيقيه تعكس ثراء الالوان الموسيقيه
في المملكه من الالحان الى الرقصات
الشعبيه التي ادتها فرق هيئه المسرح
والفنون الادائيه في المملكه بالوان
مختلفه كالخباتي والينبعاوي والسامري
والرايح والخطوه
تناغم موسيقي سعودي مكسيكي باداء الفنانين
السعوديين احدى اشهر الاغنيات المكسيكيه
وهي سيليتو لاندو التي تفاعل معها الجمهور
المكسيكي بحفاوه بالغه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تاتي مبادره روائع الموسيقى برعايه مباشره
من وزير الثقافه الامير بدر بن فرحان لنقل
جماليات الموسيقى السعوديه وتنوعها الممتد
لعشرات السنين الى كافه محبي الموسيقى حول
العالم في امسيات تبرز امكانيات موسيقيين
السعوديين وتحتفي بارث صناع ورموز
الموسيقى في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بين واشنطن وطران على اطلاق رهائن
امريكيين واجواء ايجابيه حول نووي
الاحصائي السعوديه تكشف عن نسب التضخم في
مايو الماضي وايجارات المساكن المؤثر
الاكبر مع ارتفاع بلغ 10%
وزير الاعلام اليمني يعلن تدشين رحلات نقل
الحجاج من مطار الصنعاء الى جده والمدينه
نمو شركات الدفع الهاجر في السعوديه يثير
التساؤلات استهلاكنا على لسلع ليست ضروريه
[موسيقى]
المكسيك تعيش ليله الفنيه السعوديه المحطه
الثالثه لروائع الموسيقى السعوديه
الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات